Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday. I really liked your video on Friday,
I thought you did a great job explaining Facebook's IPO,
and why stock markets are so important.
But then, at the end of the video, you said this,
"A company that gives me a free service,
that I use,
and have never
and will never pay for,
is somehow worth
one hundred
billion dollars.
What?"
Now Hank, I don't know if you intended that as a rhetorical question,
but today I am going to answer your
"what?"
And here's the thing,
broadly speaking there are two kinds of companies in this world:
there are companies that sell you things
and then there are companies that sell YOU.
Actually come to think of it,
there's a third kind of company,
the kind that sells both things and you.
Like cable companies, for instance.
Cable companies are like,
"Hey, if you give us 80 bucks a month
We'll give you the privilege of watching content funded primarily by advertising."
But anyway, Hank,
I believe that the Internet Maxim is true:
if you're not paying for a service,
YOU
are the product for sale.
Facebook is worth a hundred billion dollars because,
well actually it's not worth a hundred billion dollars,
but it's worth whatever it's worth because of you!
I mean Facebook could MySpace tomorrow,
and it would be worth nothing.
That means that companies like
Facebook or Google or Twitter or Tumblr
have to listen to their users which is a good thing.
But make no mistake,
the reason Facebook is valuable is
because you use Facebook
and you are valuable.
I mean you in particular, Hank, but also other people.
The stuff that you upload to Facebook,
whether it's wall posts or photographs or videos,
is valuable because it brings other people in to the site to look at that stuff,
and then they in turn upload their stuff,
which brings yet more people into the site.
And everything that you upload helps Facebook know more about you,
which, in turn, allows Facebook to know what you are tempted to buy and encourage you to buy it.
Now Hank, I know that you like everyone on the planet will insist that
you don't even look at ads.
And you'll insist that you aren't even conscious of what's getting hawked over there
or possibly over there,
(damn you, spatial intelligence!)
and you'll inevitably believe that you get the better end of the bargain because, of course,
you get the thing you want for free
and the ad has no effect on you.
Well Hank, let me just point out that
a.) that is exactly what advertisers want you to think
and b.) corporations actually have a really good idea of how advertisements affect your behavior.
In fact, there are many thousands of people
who are working full time to make sure that the ads you see are worth more than they cost.
To put it succinctly,
almost by definition,
advertisers buy you for less than you're worth.
I mean Hank, corporations spent $498 billion on advertising last year.
And you may think that that advertising doesn't affect your behavior,
but there is HALF A TRILLION DOLLARS that says otherwise.
You and I and anyone who uses
Facebook or Twitter or Google or Angry Birds
has agreed to be commodified.
I'm not saying that's a bad decision,
but it is a decision
and it's one that should be made thoughtfully and consciously.
Hank, we've never been totally comfortable with ads,
but it's always felt like the best solution to allow us
to make the stuff that we like with people we like.
But I don't know. Nerdfighters,
I'm interested in hearing your thoughts on this.
Should Chrysler and super-pacs and scammy online dating sites
fund Nerdfighteria?
And should we be okay with being the product?
I look forward to continuing that conversation in comments.
Hank, thanks for teaching me what an IPO is,
DFTBA, I will see you on Friday.